continúa la información entre las 24 y
volvemos con temas económicos para eso
estamos con daniela blandón que nos va a
enviar la información en esta materia
daniela el canal del suez permanece
bloqueado cuéntenos por qué o la ley en
la ley recuerdo primero que esta es una
de las rutas marítimas más concurridas
del mundo y también es orgullo nacional
de egipto pues uno de los
portacontenedores más grandes del
planeta con bandera panameña quedó
atrapado justo en este punto clave en la
ruta marítima entre hacia europa tras
perder la capacidad de maniobra lo que
ya está en investigación el canal de
suez es importante liliana porque mueve
alrededor del 10 por ciento del comercio
mundial además es la vía fluvial de unos
50 barcos cada día que representan
mercancía por unos 3.000 millones de
dólares las consecuencias económicas de
este bloqueo empeoran con el pasar de
las horas
por cada día que el canal esté cerrado
número uno significa que egipto no está
cobrando el flete de unos 700 mil
dólares por cada buque que lo atraviese
pero lo que es más importante
los buques portacontenedores no están
entregando alimentos combustible
productos manufacturados a europa y los
productos que se exportan desde europa
están llegando al lejano oriente y eso
tiene un impacto masivo en la producción
y en la disponibilidad de bienes en
europa y asia
daniela cuéntenos los anuncios
económicos de la reunión entre los
presidentes de méxico y bolivia bueno el
presidente boliviano luis arce y su
homólogo andrés manuel lópez obrador
tienen un tema muy en común liliana el
litio este mineral se ha venido haciendo
más atractivo porque es usado por
ejemplo para fabricar baterías para
automóviles eléctricos
el presidente mexicano quiere tomar un
papel más atractivo en la producción
porque dice que las concesiones que han
entregado se están usando para especular
y no para producir y luís arce por su
parte dijo que estaba muy seguro de que
el objetivo económico del derrocamiento
en 2019 de evo morales era hacerse con
el control de las reservas bolivianas de
litio
bueno daniela y hablamos ahora de nueva
zelanda porque el país ha frente a una
crisis inmobiliaria este ha sido
posiblemente una de las naciones con
mejor manejo de la pandemia sin duda
alguna pero gracias a eso también está
enfrentando un aumento inusitado en los
precios de la vivienda que la vuelven
una de las más inasequibles del mundo
esto en relación con lo que recibe cada
persona de salario en menos de dos años
los precios han subido más del 22 por
ciento antes que se podía adquirir una
casa en 450 mil dólares en promedio
ahora su valor no baja de 560 mil
dólares y en oakland inclusive que es la
ciudad más grande casi que se acercan a
los 800 mil dólares por eso el gobierno
anunció nuevas medidas liliana habrá
inversiones por 2.700 millones de
dólares para fomentar más la
construcción de viviendas también se
reducirán algunas exenciones fiscales
para los intermediarios o especuladores
y habrá más ayudas para quienes aspiren
a adquirir una vivienda por primera vez
en su vida
daniela y el vaticano se apretó
en materia económica liliana lo hizo el
papá francisco quien ordenó un riguroso
ajuste a partir del primero de abril
para tratar de mitigar el déficit de 60
millones de dólares previsto para este
año habrá recortes de salarios
dependiendo del rango del 10% por
ejemplo para los cardenales que se cree
que podrían ganar hasta seis mil dólares
mensuales muchos de ellos hay que
decirlo viven en amplios apartamentos a
precios muy por debajo del mercado otros
clérigos verán reducido su ingreso entre
el 3 y el 8 por ciento y quienes no
están cobijados por esta medida excepto
los que ganan menos como policías
bomberos y personal de mantenimiento no
tendrán aumento de salario al menos
hasta marzo de 2023 un alto prelado
citado por la agencia reuters
liliana que es dice que es la primera
vez en memoria viva que un papá toma
esta decisión bueno y vamos a hablar
ahora de los indicadores de la jornada
wall street' de cerró en rojo lastrado
por la baja de las tecnológicas como
tesla facebook o netflix en europa
cerraron mixtas las bolsas a pesar de
los datos positivos de actividad
económica en la zona euro y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo reaccionó
en negativo a una pandemia que sigue
fuera de control de este diera por la
información de colombianos es gracias
por estar entre las 24 continúan con más
tras 24 punto com
[Música]